hey you know what dude I swear to God I
woke up the other day I didn't realize
there's a there's a Starbucks in my
guest room there's a star but how did
you not know wait a minute I don't know
it so they started like someone paid the
franchise fee and have you know what I
guess so this was yesterday I'm still
there isn't she three employees crazy
other customers the other people
couldn't yes that because you don't go
around and you have a busier house
he said it's a obviously very big wait
how you know what okay so MUC C okay so
that's a Manor is that a manor or is it
a mansion don't look like you don't know
the answer to that have you seen your
being how about this what you don't I'll
let you know oh come on you're no first
of all you're never gonna get back to us
with that second of all you [ __ ]
don't mean it I'll look at your aunt's
[ __ ] crooked mouth that's not even a
thing you do that is so another thing
you do you don't do that modest right
now he's making a wad face
what's [ __ ] do you have a name for your
house is it or is just an address
probably just a house you know it's got
it what well its got like a CD on the
gate okay what what don't look at your
eyes again what is it you're so
expressive when you're lying beyond the
game no you don't have that look you're
gonna be careful you're gonna flatline
again you're gonna die if you cannot do
it I'm fine dude right now cuz I feel
really good does your place how are you
gonna [ __ ] hey man
natural causes
they lived too hard he lived too much
you do you have that that blonde draft
coffee that new Starbucks they have that
yeah it's actually one of those
Starbucks what if I don't know what they
call them Babs trying to ask the
employee Bob so it's hard it's gonna bad
and because it's a 24 do they work for
you - that's a [ __ ] manager stays I
know I should be making some sort of
money right yeah do they you know what
they might close but I don't know your
studies have the new like the new
chicken tortilla egg sous-vide Theo that
yeah not just the other two yes I think
it in Gruyere then there's yes they say
they have the but they're always out oh
[ __ ] they're always right he really has
a Starbucks at school too because if I
don't have a if I don't have a phone
charger they have those [ __ ] table
chargers yeah I can just go on and just
place my phone on there so you been you
had to know that when you went in there
you're like put a Starbucks here and
then this now do you allow anybody in
the Starbucks or is there a they they
yeah I mean yeah you can let anybody in
mostly I would say it's it's mostly
white people and okay Wow why is it just
why he was just mostly white and who
else that's a bonus I'm not trying I'm
not trying is it are you saying that you
have a white only Starbucks I don't care
I'm not judging you all right I know and
again it has nothing to do with me
it's in your home Chris no but in your
house you've been saying that yeah
that's five minute I didn't I didn't I
didn't have a I didn't know yeah we got
it we gotta talk about with your three
about a guy who's got it I mean I've got
a big house like every time he talks
about the size of his house but in a
racist cop no no no no no well I don't
have any do you do admit that they did
there is a Starbucks in my home that's a
cop I found out about
that yesterday about what that it's is
it is that why people only are there by
coincidence or is there a barrier to
entry to people who have more melanin in
their skin so I popped in about five or
six times this vicar's I I still every
time I was like wait a minute really and
I would walk in and I'd be like you're
home
yeah okay my home yeah and every time I
walk in maybe six seven eight nine times
so I had there were it was pretty much
white people don't only that okay so
wait so you're a sign or enjoyed
Starbucks so they do have signs yeah but
they have that sign that says Starbucks
and then they have a sign that says
things on this premises may cause cancer
and birth defects or whatever them and
then oh we can write we have the right
to refuse service to anyone and how much
of yeah you know that's not is there
anything there was there was small
wording under that do you know what that
said under the wearies we reserved a
right to refuse service to anyone and
then a bunch of stuff under that that
was in parentheses did it say of color
it said something like because when I
got closer to the Sun yeah this was
small right yeah yeah yeah but they were
like it's in black oh boy that's a super
you have regions can't have it you have
to change the sign that's it that's a
that's a mental that's a that's a dream
I have nothing to do sing you're outside
you're gonna be responsible for it no
matter what I have a shoe you bring this
through any court in the land
and we'll say you had it in your house
sir light right here your house worries
me judge I didn't know that no no but
you do now and here's the thing you
don't judge you've known for a day that
you have a whites-only room in your
house it's not a room it's a Starbucks
and I think honestly start out to be in
a lot of trouble
let's call it Starbucks it doesn't
matter if it's a rumor let them come try
walking chin walks in with a friend of
his who happens to also be Asian or
let's say of Latin descent or America
what can what happened let's put it this
way all stuck right there
chin doesn't walk in they have a I don't
mean III again yesterday I walk in I'm
noticing all this [ __ ] yeah
and they actually have a separate
entrance oh my how annoyed I know but
Chris what happens was I walk out and
I'm like did we stopped you when you
walked in no no it's your house but no
nobody stop me now yeah well you look
Albanian which is technically white so
there you have it so yeah so I walked
into the part you know you know the you
know when you walk into a bank and they
have the first entrance and then you
have to wait for them to have the light
turned green till we open up the second
entrance yeah okay so sort of so what
happens is no when when a bank gets
robbed if a bank is robbed there's two
entrances right and they're one after
another and the robber leaves the one
door and then they trap them in the
little area yeah to where they can't
leave the second door right yeah okay
yeah this Starbucks has a version of
that right so Chris what and you can
only make it no I'm saying it has a it
has been no plum get past the first
entrance he goes into the he's in the
chamber right so now the tension Center
so now the second entrance that would be
a red light
fortune would see a red light so he's
Chris this is how does he get his coffee
well there's I mean he's free to go
anywhere else do you want No
racist go hi I know you guys upset you
guys want to get coffee you know you got
Starbucks right now that's from the
white only star that's a racist coffee
you pay for this thing right I don't
know there every day
so what together write the name of that
dad what's it with that terrain so it
has two names right so it has it's
called the simply strawberry okay and
then and then so they said some and and
then and then under it it says made by
made with real strawberry sugar fructose
whatever sorry it's a little red we wish
that it was these people hate everyone
but what it's dude this is [ __ ] up
this this is not gonna look good not
omiai saying that but don't mess up one
day no wrong in Toros just let them in
yeah I'm mad you wake up one day you
walk into a room yeah you're out you
haven't been down that corridor or
whatever they say sometimes I hand you
open up the door no no that doesn't
happen yeah ed corridor that you had you
see all of a sudden a bunch of green and
it's a Starbucks near like holy [ __ ] I
had nothing to do with this okay that's
where I'm coming from right it happens
to be I
apparently I'm realizing now a white
zone now you're realizing that Chris
you've known Fred a full day and you
still haven't taken action have you
talked to anybody about like in some
ways so I asked the guy who works there
right and I was like what's what's his
name I'm so his name yeah his name is uh
his his name is Henry yeah yeah it's a
regular name right yeah
and so so I asked him how did what's the
deal with this right and he goes like
this I don't have anything to do with it
nobody's responsible for this insanely
racist coffee shop Henry's a white guy
who did the who put the sign I mean not
that it matters but I think Henry might
have something to do with yeah he's a
white guy okay but then you but you're
also gone I got another everybody's like
anybody there took responsibility for
their insanely race you said there were
three people yeah three other go to
other go with you so other guy yeah
Henry Zack that's right Henry yeah white
god I'm not even gonna ask yet well
Henry had Cody Cody yes those guys are
white those are white Kody's young okay
yes he probably has those parents were
like yeah let's call them exact home
jack Brian which watch this well call
him a throwback name yeah yeah my
transatlantic guy and then Cody in Sag
yes and Zack and Zack is an older man
okay he doesn't wear the the green the
apron or whatever okay so he's the man
what is he yeah sure he's a medicine
what's he wearing so he's got all sorts
of other [ __ ] going on he he might be
the one no I don't you know what I'm not
sure because he's not even wearing a
Starbucks outfit what is he wearing
that's what we're saying so he has like
this why uh uh go on [ __ ] go white
top is it a white just a-wasting exactly
yeah yeah smog is it to keep off the
zombies it's in a rhythm black oh wait
is it a verb boy hold on
is it a rope yeah I mean maybe he just
had a better he's a he's a grand wizard
does taste magical does he have little
symbols like on his would net be next to
like oh your and this is the Auto Club
and then there's like an emblem at every
red and black [ __ ] like those those
symbols like emoji symbols really so the
[ __ ] clan secretly open the Starbucks
in the Starbucks and they're profiting
and you have the Klan in your house you
have your probably probably I can gas
him out of there I was like I was like
gas about yes there's a guy in the guy
who can he shoots a gas not gonna kill
him but it'll it's a noxious gas that
will get if they have that in the
entryway it's an anti-racism between the
two entrance and anti-racist gas they
have the gas you gotta get a guy in
there okay let me tell you - I was like
what this is illegal and they go like
this dude here don't worry about it and
I'm like okay it's just weird you open
the Starbucks and I got so I drove it
here it they gave me a Ferrari they gave
you a Ferrari have money no probably
making that much money there you got
rich clamp do you have like a lot of
like probably a lot of just like white
girls going in there cuz they all love
Starbucks do they yeah they're making so
much money that they're giving them a
[ __ ] Ferrari on the side and tell
them to keep quiet
yeah so I haven't said anything up until
now are the girls though do the girls
are they or do they look like they've
been indoctrinated is there is there any
knitting and is there bacon going on do
they look like do their heads down yeah
you know a show handed yeah that's
exactly what it's like
well dude wearing bonnets and [ __ ] those
are Klan girls who are who are have low
self-esteem and they don't talk back and
probably all pretty young say anything
are they all present three there's been
three pregnant okay then can I say this
Chris have you made any of the girls
pregnant Chris say no it's Chris yeah
listen I'm asking you honestly but
please say no no you're [ __ ] well I
hear well did you make any of these
grown men
did you have sex with race you have sex
with the racist making racist babies
didn't you've known for way longer than
a day
Starbuck sorry he's bought that profits
he made off his what a [ __ ] thing
this guy's doing
he's got a [ __ ] racist are buy so
disappointed impregnating young quiet
girls and bonnets I don't know man
you're a friend and [ __ ] but like like
you gotta [ __ ] it you got a bear against
condoms of course they are you gotta
make this it feels better without so
they're like we're making up our own
rules
I've got to make this right dude you got
yeah please I will your characters have
Iran is you know we're just we I'm gonna
make it right today what are you gonna
do what do you do when you get swear to
God what I'm gonna march right down
there yeah and I'm gonna go home and I'm
gonna [ __ ] I know I'm gonna I'm gonna
after I get a coffee like a [ __ ] uh
sick I'm gonna say he's gonna get a call
you know I'm gonna do I'm gonna open up
a rival [ __ ] coffee for blacks no
blacks
well no it's actually not a bad idea
agent it has to be colorblind that's the
whole point of this guy no you gotta
have everybody in there and then and you
have to you're not gonna drive them out
of business you have to just I'll Drive
them out a bill you have to maybe he
just drives them out of business first
with the black coffee being then the
black cop now office psyching or
everybody no you have to just say this
legal and you have to just shut it he's
trying to figure out a way to [ __ ]
deal with no Brian you can't just go oh
sorry
oops fourteen months he has to
proactively get out and start a black
listen to me listen to me I know how to
solve this problem I would is I'll get
some mythography when they go in there
they're fighters yeah and
there and we'll go in there I'm gonna
come with him and we're gonna have
pieces of hickory okay and we're gonna
wear this random pieces we're gonna wear
them in our pants and then we're gonna
come in and you have one of those you
know how are we gonna get door they know
you're threatening out of the guy we're
not coming it's whites with whites we're
yeah and then hey guys what can I get
you and then I'm gonna have a [ __ ]
you got one of those doors do you have
one of those doors there's big
industrial doors because it's a
Starbucks yes I'm gonna come to one of
those big padlocks that you see on ships
with the chains yeah and I'm gonna shine
industrial like padlocks that you used
to keep to keep gold in a large chest
yeah and I'm gonna go I'm gonna pull it
I'm gonna put chain I'm gonna lock the
door and I'm gonna go there now you just
can't leave that's from Bronx Tale go on
now you can't that's the most famous
line moving can't leave shut the fuss re
sorry that's funny you'll be in the
corner crying like the [ __ ] Cowell
bring me with your the race race
apologist racist apologies my friends
gonna pull out our hickory and and have
a good old time on some racist noggins
yeah and that's how we're gonna close
your [ __ ] Starbucks down and there it
was I never saw Sonny so mad you know he
beat up all those guys at Starbucks and
they all would regretted the day day
crossed him when he locked the door and
said that and clothes and clothes about
my face as I'm done as I'm done making
mincemeat literally of all they're all
that everybody in that Starbucks was my
chicory and I just come up in there's
blood that just it just drips mmm yep
soak the whole time
you know just understand that music for
my funeral is playing and then I kill
myself
what yeah Wow weird weird I know
wait with my own head well yeah with my
guys hey so that was the longest bit
we've ever done a bit yeah 25 minutes
it's a bit racist
Starbucks out racist in their races
Starbucks is really good 30 times fast
while talking to you
why wouldn't I give that to you as it's
a gift it's a gift it's a gift